[Music]
it's just a body weight
exercise and
ground you have hour spiral
on the
elbow this is not a so I'm not going to
okay you're you're get my push but he's
not going to take you and I do my
movement my body move my shoulders and
hips move together
notice how he's not spinning around
me cuz my hands
aren't clo is back you see and then
you're going like this not doing an
incorrect version
of Boom put weight on the elbow
it's not really you can me for this
right
okay okay it's a much simpler
thing this hand goes this
way don't go
like
fo with the
okay just
down
underneath okay not over here right and
not in Kam right
okay all
right so this elbow goes this
way okay there's no need to take energy
off
here
CLA and you can see this Claw on this
andal I don't want to change the r hand
went elbows behind kind of like Ma I
don't want to do
that it's
one unit
[Music]
okay try again lose
this
okay all if you pay attention look where
his elbow
is I'm not trying to I'm not trying to
get a mechanical advantage and then go
to skeletal
alignment I'm going to do this
spiral and I'll be over the
top and lower the arm the other hand the
this is not the same clo
it all moves together as this elbow goes
in this claw open this claw see this one
closes that brings the hand to
it I don't want to go here and I'm
twisting don't look for a
mechanical just keep the
[Music]
structure if you pay attention then it's
not like your
techniques he's actually higher than me
you see pay attention he's going to be
up here when I start taking it
down I get over the top in the process
[Music]
then
look back spot so my I'm not going to
leave my hips up there I'm Bend
here I
drop drop into
it and let that pelv drop between my
legs
[Music]
and pay attention I keep the
Integrity of the Spiral
skelet I don't go for skeletal
alignment and go like
this this shape is what I want Bo
you can
see it's not here it's
here tell this through the
legs okay try
okay so now just like this girl keep's
pushing right I'm going to sink I'm let
the ches sink so I do the same thing in
motion now I got to get rid of the
tension to get it
function I have these weird shapes it's
hard
relax
move
release
release okay all right
[Music]
hey TR